develop a night dive has taken to
Kickstarter to seek nine hundred
thousand dollars for its remaster of the
1994 first person RPG system shock to
help support the campaign they've
released a free demo available right now
on steam good old games and the Humble
Bundle store the demo represents a proof
of concept according to the game's
Kickstarter page with performance
features and visuals that are subject to
change the system shock demo offers
around 10 minutes of spooky nostalgia
inducing exploratory gameplay which the
developers are hoping will whet gamers
appetites for the final product producer
of the original system shock Warren
Spector has long said that if you
updated the graphics sound and Yui on
System Shock you'd have something that
competes directly with any game on the
market today earlier this year Spectre
joined other side entertainment to lead
development on System Shock 3 the studio
is working in partnership with night
dive studios who acquired the full right
to the franchise this isn't the first
classic game night dive of remastered
having late last year released a
remaster of the original torok with
plans to tackle the sequel to rock to
seeds of evil in the future while Torok
featured updated features such as
dynamic lighting and support for high
resolution and widescreen displays
System Shock is seeing a complete
overhaul to its user interface game
mechanics enemies and puzzles which will
be updated to reflect modern aesthetics
and sensibilities while maintaining the
feel of the original did you check out
the system shock demo tell us your
thoughts below in the comments and for
everything spooky spacey inspector II
make sure to keep it locked to gamespot